[Music]
the man who until last week had a
perfect record here in a W less jump
beyond the aew world champion Chris
Jericho the being walked to the ring by
his inner circle cohort Jake Hagar the
muscle the heavy jeg heter knows
something about being undefeated Tony
yeah she not and I'm living with this
undefeated take Hagar but I wonder what
this may turn out for this
Jericho
we never know what it's gotta be sleeve
they teased it on Instagram earlier in
the day here we're waiting with bated
breath to hear with the chair noticing
master andry and Vincent he keeps
everybody off mouth they've got a damn
clue what he's going to do what he's
gonna say because he's rubbish that
place
he's agenda
he's done a lot of ground to cover of my
estimation I think he should sit down
and shut up because I've gotten an
announcements an age
you want to boo me
you want a boot Chris Jericho huh well I
said I have a huge announcement and I
have one before I make it I want to come
out here and say something you saw what
I just did last week on dynamite when I
had a a temper tantrum shall I say and I
destroyed a bunch of stuff I was fined
and had to pay for everything and it
wasn't a conduct it wasn't an attitude
it wasn't a display that a true champion
should show it wasn't conduct conducive
of this champion so I just want to come
out here and apologize I want to come
out and say that I'm sincerely
[Music]
quiet quiet I just want to say that I
sincerely this is
I just want to say that I'm very very
very to zoos tell him big hurt he said
he's sorry
[Applause]
and to show you just how sorry I am I
want to make this big announcement here
tonight next week in Chicago I will
finally get the thank you that I deserve
from aew executives or the higher-ups at
CBS Time Warner and everybody watching
here tonight and on TV and I just want
to say that I'm very sorry that the
celebration is gonna be in Chicago not
here in Indianapolis because Chicago
Chicago has a hockey team and two
baseball teams so it's a lot better than
here
[Applause]
so next week you can all sit at home and
watch Chris Jericho's Thanksgiving Thank
You celebration for the sake our next
Wednesday on dynamite that's right
[Applause]
it's gonna be the greatest celebration
saw in pro wrestling history we're gonna
have fun games prizes an aquarium maybe
some clowns I don't even know it'd still
be one of the greatest moments ever
and once again I'm very sorry but it's
not gonna be here in this stop of
Indianapolis in front of all of you
yes in front of all your bumpkins but
I'm sure you can sit